ah attends une compétition sportive pas
comme les autres sur les rives du Nièvre
à Kiev
la plupart de ces participants sont des
soldatsukrainiens amputés ils ont perdu
un membre sur le front après le début de
l'invasion russe en Ukraine
les combats les plus durs ont eu lieu à
l'intérieur de l'usine des obstacles
dans la périphérie de Mario Paul nous
avons été frappé par un missile
antichard et j'ai perdu ma jambe je vais
vous montrer comment elle a été amputée
j'ai été capturé dans cet état
ces spectateurs assis au premier rang
viennent de sortir de l'hôpital cet
événement leur permet de changer d'air
avant qu'il n'entame leur rééducation
notre but est d'inciter le plus grand
nombre de soldats à faire du sport et
améliorer leur situation ce serait une
grande victoire pour eux
de Nice a eu recours à ce centre de
prothèse après avoir été blessé le
premier jour de l'invasion russe les
médecins n'avaient pas réussi à sauver
sa jambe
lorsque vous prenez les béquilles vous
commencez à penser que vous êtes
handicapé
lorsqu'on vous apparaît avec des
prothèses et que vous commencez à
marcher il faut que vous supportiez la
douleur car les blessures n'ont toujours
pas cicatrisé
vous devez traverser cette étape et
dépasser la douleur qu'il faut
travailler avec des psychologues c'est
très important
Sacha veut rester optimiste blessé il y
a plus d'un an il est venu aujourd'hui
essayer une prothèse en fibre de carbone
il a l'intention de représenter son pays
dans une compétition sportive à
l'international
ce qui ne nous tue pas nous rend plus
fort nous devons avancer c'est pour cela
que nous allons gagner
depuis le début du conflit 10.000
blessés de guerre ont désormais besoin
de prothèses en Ukraine